the interrogation of suspects is
critical to any criminal investigation a
suspect might lie or tell the truth they
may be innocent or guilty interrogation
is a high stakes game too much pressure
and an innocent person might confess to
a crime they didn't commit most people
like to think that there is no such
thing as a false confession that some
would never confess to the crime that
didn't commit they themselves believe
that they never could be forced to
confess to something they didn't really
do yet evidence shows under the right
conditions people will make false
confessions in January 1988 a 12
year-old girl Stephanie Crowe was killed
in her own bedroom in the middle of the
night her brother Michael Crowe was
interrogated by the police they believed
he had killed his sister
just act hot he was interrogated and
eventually admitted to the crime okay
let's uh litter I meet her about I feel
that way let me hear about all I knows
it's for sorry I can't I'm building he
was charged with Stephanie Crowes murder
problem was the confession was false you
say the last time you saw Josh so why
would someone risk ruining the rest of
their life by confessing to a crime they
didn't commit
most people have the perception that a
police interrogation is a highly intense
very emotional confrontational type of
interview but in fact the more
productive interview is not of that form
more often than not an interrogator
who's using the accusatory style is
already developed a preconception before
he comes from the interviewer and what
he does is uses that narrow vision and
begins to attack your subject there has
to be an extra
are you the interrogation of Michael
crow was highly coercive
and confrontational tell us for him keep
asking questions I can't answer what do
you know
Michael crows 14 years old and he's
recently learned that his sister who he
loves Jarrell is dead I haven't liked
you he's told him repeatedly he didn't
do this
they keep accusing him they've been in
this room with him for many hours the
detective tells crow he has a choice of
two paths if he doesn't confess he'll be
punished in an adult prison if he does
confess he will get help this is a lie
there's two paths to travel there's the
path of punishment or there's the path
that says hey I'm sorry for what I did
there's the path toward rehabilitation
if he makes the confession they're
looking for that he killed his sister we
need to go down a path where we're going
to help you work this problem out and
his repentance will mean that he's not
criminally charged or punished if he
doesn't that he will go to a hardcore
juvenile prison this two paths lie is an
attempt to force Crowe into confessing
to the murder of his sister lies used in
this highly coercive manner increased
the risk of a suspect making a false
confession
another common tactic used in coercive
interrogations is a sustained attack on
a suspects memory
remember what I did I tried to turn you
you say I did it he's trying to tell
them he has no memory but they beaten
him down he's crying they're accusing
him of selective memory I don't know
and they're just coming back at him
relentlessly I can't remember means I
can't remember I can't remember
selectively is a little bit different
and here they're trying to explain to
him how he could have done this in the
absence of having any memory cuz he
keeps saying I didn't do it I don't have
any memory of this angry to park to
Michael there's a good Michael and
there's a bad Michael and the good
Michael would never hurt or kill his
sister the bad Michael did it out of
conscious awareness you're right if I
got this but it finds me good Michael
right now the other if he says remember
what's really going on though here is
that this is nothing short of child
abuse oh and he's having a breakdown
he's crying
he is psychologically tortured this is a
painful scene to watch this is an
egregious interrogation absolutely awful
interrogation
the detectives highly coercive methods
used during a 10-hour interrogation
finally we're crowed down he confesses
to a crime he didn't commit
fortunately for Michael crow evidence
was found that exonerated him for the
murder of his sister